nous avons des artistes qui ont fait
leurs visions sont venus pour nous
spécialement
on a débloqué un budget conséquent si
mais on a beaucoup d'eux et le vendredi
c'est bien connu c'est donc un live de
concetta woerth pour notre identité
j'ai pu ravir burse très bien epix axe
pour la moldavie
ja oui et alors et alors ça c'est les
jours où vous l'avez pas dit mais bill
al hassani a fait un aller-retour depuis
venir nous reprendre j'y crois c'est ce
qu'on appelle le test du poste est parti
[Applaudissements]
alors avant de commencer nous avons la
chance d'avoir un jury international
puisque le divina sera là pour la russie
accepte pas c'est bien le but c'est bien
le tibia l'audio pour l'espagne selon
bernardo nous avons amélioré pour le
crâne c'est portugal pour le portugal
pardon j'ai bien changé donc à miliana
pour l'ukraine
rachid état pour l'italie quelque chose
haddou fra francesco
et on à florian pour le fait et on à
benoît conseiller spécial pour la france
[Applaudissements]
alors on commence juste avec donc comme
c'est à vue le candidat peut vous le
savez pour des dates autrichienne ne
travestit kerry leur vision d'une 14 qui
est là ce soir et qui reprend rise lac
[Applaudissements]
on s'est parlé
[Musique]
à
on prend des notes
ça
[Musique]
c
merci merci merci contre utah si vous
pourriez retourner en autriche assez
vite ça nous arrange
maintenant on comprend pourquoi il avait
que deux copines quoi c'est très très
dur et encore il a dit là il a eu trois
ex aux imaginaires
on enchaîne avec scène avec saxo man
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
les autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa série au grain
[Applaudissements]
ap
j
merci
même si un effort bon je vois un peu
crédible même pas vicieux coup son truc
ça lui pose aucun problème c'est à dire
que là vraiment on est on est dans le
néant du rien du tout c'est à dire
claire il ya c'est je savais que c'était
une bonne idée ce happening ménage dans
ce matin jean sucre alors ses malheurs
vision alors par contre là ça arrive
être un peu mieux puisque demandait ce
sosie vocal de bilal et lola monsieur
vinel vincent village le regarde
[Musique]
un ami
mary know how will always be je suis en
vente ma fille ne me demandez pas
suit
moi je suis
le maire
[Musique]
je pleure je sors je
oui
[Musique]
bravo vraiment voilà voilà voilà ça à
ccc c'est bien fait c'est bien joué
coc tenu ces audits c'est un pro c'est
un artiste merci beaucoup et on
applaudit donc chercheur il est grand
temps de mettre des notes qui à mon avis
mon favori bien au delà
ou alors vraiment c'est que s'il avait
des problèmes politiques visuel et
olfactif alors le divina la russie pour
mr ça va gilles 12-12 parce que la corée
j'ai aimé il a tout misé sur la couler
douce sur combien à 12 sur 12 alors on a
leur vision presque pourquoi maxime et 6
à vincent bilal vinaigre ouais ok voilà
la maxime 12 fois
maxime magnifique vincent enfin bilal
deux points malheureusement mais le
talent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai assisté n'a remporté au grade
gil 6 maxime tous ces professionnels
l'air super automatique à londres et
j'ai adoré j attendais on va faire on va
faire un petit point sur les scores
d'accord ah oui merde a quand même
gilles verdez qui est en tête comme on
vous dira que c'est une catastrophe
alors si l'un d'eux maxime 6 et vincent
je ne vais lui mettre 12
voilà voilà lâché 2,18 à de pyrite allez
je vais vous dire 12 points judo et
maxime tout prendre et vincent vinel
s'expose y va doucement maxime dans un
silo 28 vilaine à l'affût l'émotionnel
est donc alors que des petits points au
classement
oui
alors autant dire que le dernier vote de
florian sera décisif beaucoup de
pression je vous rappelle que je vous
rappelle que si fait derrière florian je
vous aime beaucoup
même s'il a étayé sa main aux ex tout à
l'heure si vous faites une grosse
connerie maintenant donc on se tape le
titre en entier d'âge ça ça m'arrive de
leur faire un petit 30 et de vrd ce qui
fait en fait pas du tout du saxo de la
santé alors allez-y attention à ce que
vous allez faire florian s'est voulu
revenir dans l'émission allongée et
florian alors mon ex meghan markle mahdi
minutes
gilles ce sera six à là ça va ça maxime
2 à voilà et vous en 112 doudou et voilà
evin survie même de la france augmenté
donc
vive la france de ce classement